and from the jump like from
this was kind of started at the bottom
now we're here and you're just now
getting started
yeah it's like i said this past sunday
at that you brought up the house of
blues is
it's just a dope ass intro like all
these
all the years of just putting in work i
always feel like it's still
the first day still every time i pursue
anything whether it be an episode of
wilding out or
movie audition or just filming some tv
work
i would like that's the part of comedy
that i just never got over
every time i get that get a call for a
show i'm still excited
i still you know what i mean all that
[ __ ]
what do you think seeing the path you're
going on right now
and the mistakes you've made and the
people you've surround yourself
with what are some things comedians can
do
to really take their career into their
own hands
um this sounds crazy but you i call this
[ __ ] like the soulja boy method
it's like but a lot of like i guess a
good street transit i like terminology
would be to fake it till you make it
not even necessarily saying be a fake
person but
you got to start building the [ __ ] that
you want before
somebody else comes and validates you
you know what i'm saying like
invest in yourself and it should sound
corny but
it'll pay off in the long run because
you'll just get in the habit of doing
business like
comedians nowadays the difference that i
see from when i was
first starting and comedians now is they
don't take themselves
seriously like comedians did even when
we were
six months eight months a year into the
game you know what i'm saying
even the dude who wasn't the funniest
comedian around
still knew how to go manipulate a head
shot
or manipulate some business cards or
burn a dvd or
have a cd just something to show
[ __ ] that you was here to stay
you know what i'm saying that's the
difference
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips